Wesley so to talk about today's a quick
game with Maurice Ashley a game that he
may have needed but still might have a
chance to get in to London Wesley a draw
you just said forget London yeah a draw
really didn't seem like what you would
need to go for if you wanted to at least
break 50% in the tournament could you
tell us why you played this slide yeah
definitely I had to try well I wasn't
sure exactly I had the feeling that I
shouldn't enter the picture of today I
wasn't totally sure
so I started and I think the better off
and look at some lines and I found this
language looks a little bit interesting
at least it's been it's very original I
suppose I didn't really get that much I
mean of course I wanted to play today
but at the same time I you know I didn't
see how exactly like I don't think you
got any winning chances particularly so
maybe castling long isn't the best I'm
not totally sure you it seems that
equalized quite easily you said of
course you wanted to play today yeah I
lost for you doesn't it doesn't seem
like a big deal if even if you lost the
game it seemed like going for it would
still be a good idea yeah but tell me
how to go for it considered some some
lines but they didn't particularly look
that convincing and you know fab is in
great form here um well of course wants
to play for when I just didn't see you
know maybe I should play the bird I
should I will consider briefly to bring
the bird opening with every or maybe I
should have a chef gone for for that
yeah and yeah unfortunately you know I I
was looking really forward to my first
win I mean yesterday I have some chances
but I watch it up in time turbo
well now term is over you know it's time
to prepare for the next one and I like
to congratulate fatty and
doing such a phenomenal job here's what
the tournament yeah yeah I mean chances
that's one could catch it
yeah but fair congratulations on a great
play seems like a good sign for if match
in the London chef classic America the
world champion yeah yeah in the world
championship of course in in London
might also make the London chest classic
yeah
you also could make the London chest
plastic there is a mathematical chance
even with a draw that you'll get in
depending on the live one and Magnus has
to win dónde right right to push back
back we are yeah so they've won in
magnifies the wind not very likely
considering that know how many 85% of
the games here and in drawers is it a
bird yeah yeah personally I might play
here has been very much subpar well I
should have started playing better from
the very first rapid game in the first
tournament I didn't realize how
difficult it is to qualify for for
London but oh whatever can only do my
best and I'd like to thank Rex and
Jeanne for hosting this event still
giving there's a lot of chances I hope
to play much better next time I'll be
back next step for you is the Olympiad
what you looking forward to that well we
have this little 916 oh yes yeah I kind
of embarrassed an issue by losing the
first game I didn't make 9 draw but I'm
interested to see how that 960 will go
because I've never really played in a
terrain before and the first tournament
I've heard of it being held is a match
between Magnussen hakuro
so not even sure exactly how to prepare
for the chess960 so we have that
Yassir has a few ideas of
but but yeah so yes I hope to start
winning some some tournaments and just
you know my time here in st. Louis
haven't been particularly very good your
classical chess 2016 was just a
spectacular year for you even the
beginning of 2017 I believe you won talk
to steal you know I need to bring those
good days back you need to have more
focus in termination we'll see hopefully
all right we know you got ton of
potential so we expect to see you back
in the winner's podium sometime soon
thing tomorrow
good luck in your next event thank you
Thank You Wesley